welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is thomas graham a senior fellow at the
jackson institute for global affairs at
Yale University mr. Graham is a managing
director at kissinger associates where
he focuses on russian and eurasian
affairs he was special assistant to the
President and Senior Director for Russia
on the National Security Council staff
from 2004 to 2007 and director for
Russian affairs from 2002 to 2004 as a
senior fellow mr. Graham is teaching a
seminar on cybersecurity for students in
the global affairs major and that is
what we will talk about with him today
welcome mr. Graham glad to be here let's
begin with the term cyberspace and let
us know what that means and then I'm
curious to know what its chief
components are let me start by saying
that this really is an exciting field at
this point as you probably notice
there's been mounting interest in cyber
issues cyber security over the past
several months I don't think there's a
think tank in Washington or New York
that hasn't had a conference isn't
planning to hold a conference on cyber
issues in the next several weeks I
attended one yesterday in New York the
Council on Foreign Relations is set up a
task force to focus on Cyprus issues and
their meaning for American commerce
American security going forward you
might have noticed that Secretary of
Defense Panetta gave a major speech and
cyber issues raising the threat of a
cyber 911 cyber Pearl Harbor last week a
few months before that the President
himself authored a an op-ed in the Wall
Street Journal on cyber issues so it
really is an exciting time to be doing a
capstone on cyber issues at the Jackson
Institute now to answer your question
cyberspace what is it you have to
remember that this is a fairly new feel
so one of the things that has to be done
is agree on with the terminology what is
cyberspace
the US government has define cyberspace
as and if I get this right it's the
interdependent network of information
technology infrastructure including the
Internet telecommunication systems
commuter computer networks and
processors and controllers in critical
in critical industries now what does it
include and lose a lot of hardware so
all these mobile towers that you see
around the country are part of it your
computer can be your your iPhone um
satellites optic fiber networks and so
forth it's also includes a lot of
software all those things that the micro
sauce and other IT companies / to
produce that you put on your computer
some people would argue that actually
includes all the information that might
be stored in various parts of cybers of
the digital in the world so anything
that's digital in the fact fits in
cyberspace in some way the pentagon
calls this a domain they call it the
fifth domain in which they have to be
able to operate efficiently the other
four domains are land water air and
space now what makes cyber space
different from these is it's man-made
and we're in a period of very rapid
technological change so as the
technology develops as new applications
are put forward in fact cyberspace
itself grows and expands and diversifies
again that's one of the things that
makes it such an exciting field so how
central is cyberspace to our economic
prosperity and national security the
short answer is critical more and more
important every day I would imagine
exactly and as the technology develops
it will become increasingly important
for individuals for business for the
national government I mean think about
the ways in which you impact act in
cyberspace
every day when you go on online to shop
you're in cyberspace when you exchange
emails or text messages with your
friends using cyber space if you're
telecommuting you're doing that through
cyberspace on the business side we have
banking transportation networks all
dependent on on cyberspace for for
functioning ah and you know for the u.s.
government particularly for the military
the military is becoming increasingly
what they call net-centric for running
their operations but you think about all
that whiz-bang stuff that the Pentagon
likes to show off their drones for
example that's cyberspace precision
guided munitions that goes through
cyberspace in some way so we are an
increasingly wired society society
increasingly dependent on cyberspace
probably more so than most any other
major country in the world although
clearly cyberspace is beginning and use
of the cyberspace is beginning to grow
elsewhere in the world faq globally
there about a billion users a cyberspace
right now at a seven billion in the next
few years by two or three four billion
people in cyberspace and I just make
this final point about it we need to
remember that if you think about the
internet for example that it was
developed over the past decades
primarily for ease of access people
wanted to connect with one another and
they wanted to make it as easy as
possible to do that people paid very
little attention to the security of
these systems in recent years as we've
become more dependent on this technology
there's been an increasing focus on the
security and that's one of the big
challenges that we face as society as a
government is how to ensure that these
systems that have become so critical to
our day-to-day lives are secure that we
can confident that our privacy is
protected to confidentially alia for
information is protected and that it
still works in a way that makes life
easy for x well let's talk about some of
the threats you know what should we be
concerned about the first point to make
here is that
in generic terms these types of threats
have been around for as long as there
have been men and women you have crime
you have espionage you have attacks that
can go all the way from vandalism to
warfare in one way or another what's
cyber adds to this is a different
dimension the speed and the
communication moves at the speed of
light lang think of the volume of
information that you can pack into a
thumb drive or a CD much more condensed
than before in cyber space all / also
now provides for a level of anonymity
that you didn't have before so think
about your personal life someone wanted
your money there were a few ways they
could do it before the advent of the the
internet he could rob you you could
break into your house and steal whatever
money had there if it was really good to
get forward to check and get a bank to
cash it for him in cyberspace a
cybercriminal if he's able to get you or
trick you into providing him your user
ID and your password he can go any clear
out your account and a matter of minutes
a few keystrokes he can sell off your
entire stock portfolio for you and move
it to some offshore account that he
controls so that's a major change if you
think about cyber espionage again before
you had to break into the facility you
had to know where the documents were
located that you wanted you have to find
those documents you had to copy them in
some way then you had to get them out
even after you got them out your end
user may have been somewhere else in the
world so how you're going to get those
back to the to the end user now a very
capable cyber spy can actually access
some of this remotely because it's
concentrated in in several files you can
download this information very quickly
you can take 250 thousand pages that
would have taken years to copy put it on
a disk exfiltrate it out of the country
again in the matter
of minutes so that has changed
dramatically and also the level and on
that anonymity never quite sure who's
stolen your information and even now
we're having more of a problem with the
cyber attacks think of cyber vandalism
and this is really these a denial of
service attacks that deface websites
that may be slow down very various
systems we've read in the past couple of
days about Iran attacking your banking
system for example websites have gone
down people haven't had accents that is
somewhat of a threat but I don't think
you should exaggerate it's a nuisance
you have to wait a few hours before the
websites up and you can conduct those
operations what people are beginning to
focus on now at the highest levels are
our government it's a possibility for
what they call cyber warfare but Panetta
called the cyber 911 the cyber Pearl
Harbor where hostile actors I have an on
state or nation state go after our
critical infrastructure such as what
they could go at a the entire banking
system they could go at our power grid
you know all our power grid is
controlled by a set of embedded
processors basically what they call
skoda's supervisory control and act with
that acquisition mechanisms if you can
break in get the code redo the the
controlling functions you can bring down
the power grid well how easy is that to
do though I mean I would hope that the
government or whomever controls that
would have measures put in place to
prevent that and the the short answer is
if that you take the appropriate
security measures it becomes much more
difficult to do this but you have to
remember that most of these controllers
are commercially produced in the private
sector that eighty-five percent of
cyberspace in the United States is
controlled by the private sector not by
the government on people are lazy
many we have found that many of these
control mechanisms use that as the
password the default password 123456 or
123 password so it was very easy for an
11 and actor to set a guess that's what
they were there into the system and then
they begin to rejigger the files or send
different types of controls damage the
control system in some way and that is
still a problem although we've greatly
enhanced our awareness of this problem
over time but still incentivizing people
to do that making them aware of that
again when you're talking about
thousands of individuals hundreds of
companies and firms that have to do this
is in fact a tremendous national
security do we have does the u.s. have a
strategy in place well US government is
developing a strategy and the almost
every department in the US government
has published a cyber strategy for
itself the White House is published an
overarching cyber strategy for the for
the US government we want the system to
be global we want it to be open we want
it to be secure now and there's a lot of
effort that's going into this area but
it really is a very complex area to deal
with remember as I said much of
cyberspace lies beyond the government's
control so you have to have
public-private cooperation if you're
going to to enhance our security and
once you begin to talk about the
security measures you take you have to
satisfy the concerns of our national
security apparatus as largely government
but some people outside of government
the business community which remember is
in in the business of making profits
killer and they will always do the
cost-benefit analysis on security and
then you have civil society this
concerns are our privacy the
confidentiality of our information so
getting all the various interest groups
on to the same page
developing a security approach that
makes a secure allows business to make
make profit but at the same time allows
all of us to have the privacy that we
want is actually a very difficult and
complex political task the reason that
Congress couldn't pass legislation on
cybersecurity this summer is in fact
because it couldn't get those three
groups to come to a common position on
how to deal with these issues so we'll
have that problem going forward now
there's also an international action I
was going to say are we working with any
other countries remember you know
cyberspace contrary to what a lot of
people believe is not in international
comments there are physical objects to
it you know as we've talked about those
are located in specific countries and
yet the way the system operates if
you're sending a message from here to
someone in Europe it could go through an
infinite number of routes to get there
and so will cross and use the facilities
that are located in various countries so
to make ourselves secure make the system
efficient and operable globally we have
to work with other countries on this and
so yes the United States has a series of
dialogue a series of cooperative efforts
which are the main countries are we
working with well home are we working
with China for instance well you see it
varies from what you can do from country
to country obviously a cybersecurity a
cooperation and cybersecurity is based
to great extent on trust so we can do
most those countries that we trust most
and so not surprisingly we work well
with the United Kingdom we work well
with some of our NATO allies even there
there are sort of differences in how
this should be done Japan South Korea
for example China and Russia are
somewhat different issues not you can't
ignore them you have to talk to them
about this but what you talked about the
range of issues how you
about that marriage in part because we
see Russia and China particularly from
the ass the aspect of cyber espionage is
probably two of our greatest threats
right so it's a it's a difficult
conversation I guess how how concerned
should we be in terms of an actual cyber
attack occurring and and will it take
something like a cyber attack for people
to finally start working together do you
think well this is one of the big issues
you know there never has been a cyber
world the Secretary of Defense might
talk about it but the fact is that no
one has ever died from a cyber attack
that we know of there's been limited
physical damage done through cyber
attacks the Stuxnet that we talked to
read about over the summer that attacked
the centrifuges in Iran one of the few
examples of a cyber weapon being used to
actually produce physical damage in some
way but there hasn't been a major war we
haven't seen electric grids taken down
at least as far as we know because of
cyber weapons that's all hypothetical
based I think on very good assessments
of what the what the potentials are what
the vulnerabilities are but the fact is
we know nothing about how a cyber war
would actually be conducted that's 12 as
you as you know moving people to deal
with this type of vulnerability
generally happens after the
vulnerabilities had been exposed in a
major way I think of what we did on
terrorism after nine eleven now if I can
bring in my Russian background there's
an old saying that the peasant only
crosses himself once only after there's
lightning haha so there is a tendency
not to do the preparatory work that you
need that said I think one of the things
that the US government is trying to do
from the President on down
is to sensitize people to the threat to
make it clear that this is serious and
that we need to find as a country as
society a way of dealing with this so
that we can all enjoy the very good
great benefits of an interconnected
world that we live in and that we
prosper in okay what do you think the
future holds for cybersecurity well it's
going to be a growth field I mean I
think that's quitter you know one of the
problems that all of us have in dealing
with this is separating the reality the
real threats from the height cyber
security as I said has become an issue
over the past a couple of years you have
various government departments
particularly at a time when budgets are
being restricted for various reasons
they want to say you know this is a
serious issue we need to deal with it
we're going to need more money but look
at this range of threats that we had all
the horrible things that it can happen
some of that is real some of that is
hype for us outside of there but also
inside government we need to get focused
on what the real threats arm and then
begin to devise solutions this isn't is
it and this will take some in terms of
the real threats i mean i would imagine
someone would have to be very
knowledgeable about you know the
computer system and therefore have a
very good education so I think it's
somewhat unlikely that there are very
many people out there who would be able
to take down a system I mean is that
correct or not I mean well and who you
know who are these people who you know
who would want to do a cyber attack well
first point to make is the number is
growing day by day per second remember
that there are various countries now
that are developing cyber weapons the US
government set up Cyber Command a couple
of years ago main goal is defending the
United States but it's become
increasingly clear in the comments by
senior officials that we also have a
festive
offensive weapons as well the Russians
the Chinese when go down the list about
two dozen countries are very serious
about developing cyber weapons at this
point it's not something that
necessarily an individual sitting in a
basement can do you can face a website
but producing these types of
sophisticated cyber weapons you would
need for a future cyber war actually
takes a higher level of capability but
nation states are capable with that and
you know certainly what we have seen
over the past several years is various
countries a probing us systems we don't
know entirely what they might have left
behind on the system that will allow
them access in the future again that's
one of the challenges is making sure the
system is clean of all types of mal
winner if you can have confidence in it
and it's functioning so yes it's not
something that everyone can do but there
are growing numbers of technologically
sophisticated people using the resources
of states that can do this and that will
increase in time right well hopefully as
that increases will also be increasing
ways to prevent that from happening no
absolutely I think we're all much more
aware of cybersecurity not certainly in
our personal lives yes this is becoming
an issue in government let me just make
the final point that's not only about
technological skills it really is a
political problem at the end of the day
most of the people who are going to make
the decisions what our cyber strategy gr
don't have a clue as to how this really
works in the real world sort of like
nuclear weapons right before I you have
an idea of what they can do you know
you've got a bunch of people over here
who know the technical details but
you've got to think through the
political strategy how you bring people
together to pursue a certain set of
goals and that takes tremendous amount
of political sky
and time to time well thank you so much
for being here that's been fascinating
you're certainly welcome for more
information about Thomas Graham and his
work please visit our website at yale
edu slash McMillan report be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
McMillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
you